what you got playboy Bubba I'm just
wondering where your stocks on this
virus probe you think it's coming for
you you got you're doing it precautions
take care of yourself I just want to
know what you got that coronavirus bent
Cove in nineteen wonder if you guys know
or not but the primate center that I
grew up around and Covington Lousiana
and why you know they had us out there
wrangling chimps and when I was probably
I don't even know just I don't even know
how all I what maybe titty high on a
middle-aged woman you know top of the
titty but you know uh they gave that
same Center where monkeys escaped in my
hometown growing up they gave them forty
million dollars to fight this virus or
to try and cure it dude I'm telling you
this man in my town bar they ain't
curing [ __ ] man you know what I'm saying
no doubt I'm not saying but look they
got a Popeye's four blocks from the
frickin primate Center they nobody's
curious [ __ ] around there am i saying
they're not doing a decent job or this
or that or they're not going to test and
do the tests and stuff but look if you
come down by the Tchefuncte River and
you expect us to solve that all save the
world we're not doing that we don't do
that we want the monkeys to have a
little fun we want everybody to flare up
a little we doing Mardi Gras we doing
recipes we saw ween doing all that a
[ __ ] saving everybody that's not us
somebody has to go somebody has to go to
heaven somebody has to go to hell we the
would we I grew up in us in a stray
animal Belt
I grew up in this and in a area where
the number one currency is is anecdotes
and store
and memories you know that's that's the
vibe of Louisiana it's about the it's
about the fun and about the the mystery
and so that's what you get around us so
you come down and you can pump 200
billion you could put a villian dollars
in 200 billion baby or 1 billion and
look I'm telling you being better all
just buying you a a dozen of fresh
oyster with a little bit of bread
pudding dessert and calling it a wrap
son and save your monkey and save you
money too but what do I think about the
coronavirus here's what I think I think
I think we'll never know right now how
real things are how real things aren't I
don't believe you could trust I do not
believe you could trust news out of
China I do not believe that you could
trust mainstream media to to tell you
anything that doesn't have some other
side of it for them or you know they
want you they want to scare us because
they can sell ads they keep us glued to
their television you know I think it's
always a good idea to take care of
yourself you know it seems like it
sounds like the cold it sounds like the
flu and it doesn't seem like
statistically compared to bigger does
compared to other diseases to that it's
really doing anything you know you could
die of anything now and you could just
say it's Khurram is it sound like the
Vegas [ __ ] I've ever heard but it just
sounds real popularized you know it's
like there's always been you know swine
flu there was SARS remember all of this
nobody nothing nobody ever none of that
[ __ ] did anything nobody knows anybody
that died from SARS what no some people
thought it was a test one guy took it
now he's an attorney now
tell us how to Folsom over there in
Livingston Parish Louisiana so it's hit
or miss but this is a Miss I think for
me I just don't now do I think that I
think it's a perfect I think this is a
perfect example for us to see the power
of the media and how much they can scare
people and we're just at a time now
where people don't believe the news
anymore rightfully so and they shouldn't
and it's a great time to take care of
yourself and take care of your own and
trust your instincts you know the number
one news source that most of us have I
think is our instincts I mean sometimes
it's hard to read them but but that's
okay if something bad if you get them
wrong you get the instincts wrong you
read them wrong and you mess up then
that's why you got to be a good person
because then you go to heaven baby and
then they got what you want up there
they got the snack table baby they got
unlimited videos they got it all good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one